[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
as if that were possible so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
because this show is pretty much
perfection ma'am tonight tonight a fan
named Billy says he thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened when I was
talking about a glitch in the new madden
15 NFL video game Conan Conan you messed
up man you messed up and I caught you
last show you did a segment about NFL
linebacker Christian Kirksey apparently
there was a Madden NFL 15 glitch where
he's only like a foot tall here he is in
action in the video game
but you made a critical mistake you were
making fun of him and you said I'm open
I'm open and if you knew anything about
football you'd know that NFL linebackers
don't say I'm open wide receivers do do
you even do even watch football do you
even lift bro
anyway you busted let's see get out of
that one well first of all Billy you're
minutes away from death by falling into
an open manhole
if you cannot walk around an urban area
yelling at me and then not looking where
you even lift but I thought he had it I
thought he had a very original complaint
and I think he presented it very well
the only problem is you are wrong buddy
NFL linebackers do say I'm open don't
believe me well maybe you'll believe the
man himself Cristian Kirk see from
Madden 15 hey well I say I'm hoping all
the time sometimes I yelling at the
quarterback to mess with them and make
them throw an interception well other
times too like when I open my own ice
cream shop on the first day I spent
outside it yeah I'm open oh just the
other night when the male hooker came up
to me on the street I said I'm open so
you see Billy Cohen is right in your
[Applause]
why
[Music]
why what why a cobra why a woman with a
broom
I mean why there's so many things I
don't understand
obviously her pet Cobra and she was
protecting it oh good man
all right so the challenge still stands
if you think we spotted an arrow on our
show reported a team koco.com slashed
ha-hi find the net we will sort it out
right here on the air let's see if you
have what it takes to make chunk meat
out of the maestro
you